to the bone is directed and written by
Marti Noxon and stars lily collins as
ellen a young girl who is dealing with
severe anorexia she agrees to a radical
form of treatment where she goes to a
house with other people who are
suffering from various eating disorders
and their primary physician is Keanu
Reeves now can you imagine anyone on
this planet that you'd want to make you
feel better more than Keanu Reeves I
can't
this film is out on Netflix now and I
watched it tonight and I was riveted by
scene 1 this film pulls no punches it's
a bleak dark sometimes very disturbing
movie about eating disorders and what it
can do to someone psychologically and
physically but also what it can do to
someone's family and anyone who cares
about that individual it's about the
struggle that comes with any eating
disorder but primarily anorexia which is
what Lily Collins character Ellen is
dealing with she doesn't want to eat she
doesn't even want to bite into food let
alone swallow it she is repulsed by the
idea of ingesting anything that contains
calories and this isn't something that's
you know corny I've actually read some
critics reviews after seeing the film
that described the plot as hokey or
corny I've known people with very severe
eating disorders and there's nothing
corny about it and this film is highly
accurate at its portrayal of what
someone can go through I am very
impressed with Lily Collins work in this
movie her performance is definitely a
standout she clearly lost quite a bit of
weight for the role but it's not just a
weight loss that's a standout the the
look of the character she inhabited the
character beautifully and her
performance is one that is very guarded
which is something that people who go
through things like this can sometimes
develop that mentality where you don't
touch me you know I'm closed to you
leave me alone and that's something that
she really portrayed so well and she
shined in this movie and I was very
impressed with her work and Keanu Reeves
also is hitting a real
léa good note in this film his doctor is
highly entertaining he's not the kind of
guy that just walks in and goes how you
feeling today oh good he'll pick
yourself up and have a nice day here's a
prescription for something he will look
you in the eye and say fuck those
thoughts that you're feeling and he'll
literally say that he'd be like fuck the
thought sure that you're thinking right
now that make you not want to eat he is
a very entertaining character and I
thought he was really well-written and
he did a good job in the movie too
there's also a young guy named Luke at
this house he is played by Alex sharp
this character was once a dancer who
injured his leg and then had a really
hard time eating after that he basically
tortured himself mentally and now here
he is trying to gain the weight back
I thought he was a revelation in this
movie he reminded me in a very strange
way of a young Hugh Grant I thought he
was very charming and I liked his
performance quite a bit and it took a
while for me to appreciate his character
the first few scenes I was like ooh this
guy might be a little too much but he
really grew on me and I thought that his
character had a really nice arc this
movie also features work from Lily
Taylor who I think is one of the most
underrated actresses working I I've
never really seen anyone talk about her
really and she's fantastic and
everything and she's great here once
again as Ellen's biological mother there
is a crushing scene in the third act of
this movie near the end that just
flattened me it was so good and on paper
it could have gone so wrong and it just
hit the right note and it leveled me
emotionally the acting is fabulous it's
well-written it has intriguing
characters there's some moments towards
the end that didn't quite jive with me
where the movie gets a little
transcendental that's my best way to
describe it and I was just kind of like
okay we're getting a little theatrical
here beyond that I was really impressed
with this movie I think it's a film that
traverses subjects that are difficult to
talk about very carefully but it doesn't
try to hide anything and it certainly
isn't politically correct and that's
something I loved characters in this
movie
say words or phrases that are considered
now inappropriate people are spoken to
very rudely and no one comes out saying
hey you can't say that this movie has
certain phrases and people say and do
certain things that would be considered
inappropriate and they just do it these
are a bunch of characters and a really
low point in their lives they're not
sure if they're even going to be alive
next week and and they no longer care
about things like that and it also as a
viewer put me in a place where I felt
their pain and that's all due to
excellent writing and great performances
I'm going to give to the bone and a -
it's on Netflix now I check it out at
least for the performances I also want
to thank Jason Taylor one of my viewers
he sent me this now
I met Colin Trevorrow I got a chance to
interview him and good old Jason
remember that and had a chance to meet
Colin and he actually printed this out
for me and got Colin autograph on it for
me and this was a surprise he sent me in
my p.o box
you're an amazing viewer and I just want
to say thank you so much for that that
was really really sweet of you that was
that really brought a smile to my fan
and my wife's my face both of our face
we were just like oh my god it's just
too nice thank you so much guys you are
the best and as always if you like this
you can click right here and get stuck
mine eyes
[Music]